next to face the video evidence is
Chinese winner you and you from
Blackburn and Lancashire father
Charlie's son head chef Victor were
overjoyed to win their heat you and you
oh but I had concerns they were heavily
overstaffed burns next top model it's an
issue that needs to be addressed i
Alaska
the problem is when you get a lot of
staff and the restaurants not very busy
it's more interested in understanding
owner gossip and actually looking after
the customers with you and you that was
my one big concern
what's the point on all those staff when
they're not looking after customers
seems to be a different person that
calmness I don't know someone's
responsible for chopsticks and
somebody's responsible a clear objective
get one wait when waitress or waiter
it's not the way to have a warm service
you don't make customers feel relaxed
every time something hits the table it's
a new waitress I'm looking for the best
restaurant on the daily basis with the
best food and the best service and I
want to see restaurants get better
despite the setback I'm pleased to see
you and you are still serving a
wonderful food nice nice crunchy apple
but I fear that we stopped at this nice
and crunchy and the batter's actually
really light it tastes really glass
that's a real strong element with you
and you they are constantly pushing the
boundaries out and they're trying to
reinvent Chinese cuisine but with her
21st century approach nice nom Jim was
my champion Thai from some Andrews in
Scotland it's a great restaurant but my
undercover cameras discovered really
surprising problems with service
what ranks as a powerful most aggressive
service I've ever seen in my life
with my new secret diner get better
treatment you know the beat Poorna Corey
you don't do a lot of chicken or great
flexibility from a dining room staff um
she when the chicken will be curry she
wanted prawns and so they did it it
wasn't even on the menu
the service is miles better what about
the food when I went down I discovered
that some of the dishes were slow in
leaving the kitchen that's not how the
sauce isn't hot and the the writers are
very warm I they should be really honest
potato dad
food not piping hot it was also the
concern their food hangs on the hot
plate it shouldn't sit there as it sits
there the goodness is disappearing but
more importantly the food's getting cold